good afternoon everyone this is Laura
McDermott speaking on behalf of the
northeast ser funded soil management and
buried crops as a model for management
education project this is the 12th
webinar in a series of 12 the final
webinar so I really am happy that we've
got a good group and thank you for
logging on we I think most of you know
your way around this Adobe Connect
classroom you put a chat in that long
narrow box right in the lower center
that's how you communicate there are web
links here for the webinar archives in
case you've missed any and to Northeast
air and then just on the apparently
according to kathy there are a couple of
folks that have not finished the
Northeast air demographics questionnaire
we would really love everybody to do
that it's something that we need to have
done for the grant and I do there's
going to be more information about this
but this is concluding the first year of
this project the webinars are part of a
two-year northeast air professional
development project and we'll have more
information about the second year's work
at the end of this presentation and then
Cathy heidenreich will also discuss the
post-test and the webinar evaluation
that we'd like everyone to complete at
your leisure so without further ado I
think we'll we'll move into the second
phase the last educational presentation
of the webinar series dr. Harold Venice
it will be giving Harold as the
professor of soil modern management and
chair of the Department of crop and soil
Sciences at Cornell University his
current research and extension interests
are in precision management of nitrogen
soil health and space time statistics
and today he's going to be speaking
about soil management using ecological
principles and soil health management
all right here well thank you thank you
laura i hope you can all hear me good
day so in this final webinar I'd like to
kind of bring together some of the
management approaches that we've
discussed in the in the past months and
and perhaps think about it a little bit
more at a conceptual level especially
how we can bring ecological principles
into into sustainable very management so
a little bit about agroecology miguel
Altieri defined it as the application of
ecological science to the study design
and management of sustainable
agriculture of course relates to how
organisms interact with with their
environment and even though agricultural
systems almost by definition are not
natural systems there's a lot we can
learn from natural systems and and
that's also applicable to agriculture
system it can enhance the agricultural
systems by basically mimicking some of
the natural processes especially how
various organisms interact so this could
be so organisms like worms or fungi or
bacteria it could be plants either our
berry plants which were primarily
concerned about or other plans that that
might interact with them like like maybe
cover crops or mulch or something like
that it the idea is that it encourages
beneficial biological interactions
synergies and efficiencies and that
recycles nutrients energy and carbon in
favor of external inputs where possible
and that it it kind of approaches
multiple tactics so with this this
latter point we we mean that you know we
tend to bring in a lot of external
inputs into agricultural systems and
most of the time that's necessary to
have the production potential that we're
looking for
but there's a lot of internal cycling
that we can take advantage of and it
really it's a it's a framework for
approaching agricultural management that
is really much more knowledge intensive
and in a way I think that's been the
purpose of the seminar where we where we
discussed a lot of approaches that are
not simple and there's often not very
easy prescriptive recipe type answers
but that need to be that need to bring
in basically our knowledge of the system
inis and and how the interactions within
the system occur so this graph here
shows five legs of a table that
represents natural ecosystems and and
these are basically represent five
characteristics of natural ecosystems
they tend to be self-regulating they
tend to be efficient they are diverse
they are generally self-sufficient and
they are resilient so let's look at
those in a little bit more detail so
when we think about a natural ecosystem
you know you have to keep in mind that
these systems have evolved over over the
years and and basically have come up
with with what you might want to call a
successful formula so they are they have
to be efficient in terms of energy in
terms of nutrients water and carbon and
they tend to cycle quite efficiently
within a natural ecosystem there's
typically very little waste because one
organisms waste is another's resource in
in agricultural systems we often have a
lot more waste and external losses like
for example nitrate leaching or runoff
that that would be wasteful in a natural
environment and and we have to minimize
those in in a more modest environment
they tend to be diverse above and below
ground biological activity or diversity
leads to checks and balances if we think
about soil organisms
we have been official ones we have
pathogenic organisms and they tend to
keep each other in check above ground we
have different plant organisms that also
impact and compete with each other and
and basically provide a balance there
they tend to be self-sufficient the only
external inputs tend to beat sun light
rain and air and and not many of these
other external inputs that we normally
see in agricultural systems so they
evolved basically to be efficient and to
to basically take advantage of the
limited resources that they have
available they are self regulating they
have diverse o'clock ecological
communities and severe disease or pest
outbreaks tend to be uncommon again
because of this diversity and keeping
the checks and balances their
populations tend to be dynamic and
continuously influx and last but not
least they tend to be resilient you know
many natural systems have been subjected
to extreme events whether it may be
extreme precipitation like a hurricane
or or extreme cold or extreme dryness
and that way they've basically adapted
to those kind of environments and
they've built resiliency into their
ecosystems they can be damaged but they
tend to come back easily more easily
than than a damaged ecosystem so the
question then is which of these can we
achieve in agriculture and I think we
have to be realistic that that
agriculture by its very design is not
natural because we basically try to
favor one plant or berry crop in this
case over other plans but we can still
take advantage of a lot of the
principles of natural ecosystems so
let's start it maybe contrast that a
little bit to sort of the the more
conventional agricultural approach and
how
many of us have learned about managing
agricultural systems the most dominant
paradigm in agriculture is is more
reactive management short-term response
to immediate problems that relies on
external interventions and we have some
examples here for example if you're low
on nitrogen then you apply a nitrogen
fertilizer if you have an insect problem
then you apply an insecticide if you
have weedy conditions you apply an
herbicide if the soil is dry you
irrigate the soil is compacted you use a
subsoiler or something like that now
sometimes these problems can be symptoms
of deeper or more fundamental problems
maybe a poorly managed ecosystem and
this also tends to be a relatively short
term approach to things we might think
of in tilt systems we might think of
tillage that way as well that we have a
short-term benefit from tillage but in
the longer term we do damage to the to
the land now the two contrast that a
more agro ecological approach is more
proactive and looks more at the
long-term and the idea here is to
develop internal strength into the
system that allows it to be more
efficient more resilient and all those
qualities that we'd like to see in in
good agroecosystems so we like to use
strategies that enhance mutualism and
synergies you know many of the for
example of the soil biota can enhance
plant growth mycorrhizae are one example
of that we'd like to be able to stress
the pest and enhance the beneficials and
create soil and above ground conditions
that promote growth of healthy crops
with enhanced defenses and the analogy
that I often use when I talk to students
or or stakeholders is is the analogy
with human health which we've used
before and when you think about
proactive long-term management it's the
analogy would be to basically live a
healthy lifestyle
to to eat healthy say a high-fiber diet
with fruits and vegetables not too much
meat and to exercise and and and
basically live all the live a lifestyle
that's that's low of stress that
basically gives you internal strength
and health in your body the contrast
there in terms of the more reactive
management would be more like getting
sick or say getting a bacterial
infection and taking antibiotics and
there's nothing wrong with that it's
good to do that at the time but what you
also like to do is you'd like to be able
to to build that strength into the
system over the long term so when you
think about the human health you know
eating a healthy meal eating a salad or
eating some fruits and vegetables or
some high fiber breakfast doesn't
overnight make you into a healthy person
you need to have a long term commitment
to good diet and exercise to become
healthy and to build the strength in the
in your in your body to be able to
withstand a diversity of conditions so
the analogy is really very similar you
want to focus on on at least having a
long-term strategy in managing your
ecosystem your aegyo ecosystem to reduce
the the susceptibility to stress and
build resiliency and strength in the
system so that's basically captured in
this graph that you can see here and
there's basically three components the
first is this long term preventive
management the second is a little bit
more shorter term sort of seasonal
management and then the third one is the
real short term reactive management and
so if we if you look at the start with
the preventive management we can think
of sort of an aboveground component and
a below-ground component so let's start
with that with the latter if we think
about you
building healthy soils these are some of
the management practices that we
discussed earlier start out with
assessing your soil try to improve the
soil even before you you plant your your
berries make sure that the pH is
corrected at organic matter 22 to build
up the the carbon levels in the soils
reduce compaction problems all those
kind of things that are sort of
preventative longer term management
approaches we think about above-ground
good crop selection you know select
varieties that are resistant to certain
diseases make sure that they are planted
well things like that that basically
will enhance the success of your of your
plant so this then we'll create soil and
above ground conditions for healthy
plants with enhanced defenses so a
second level then you might think of
sort of in season management and this is
more sort of planned in season
management think in terms of integrated
pest management so you basically you
commit to a set of practices that help
you better manage plus pests and you're
in your crops for example you commit to
two weekly field inspections and
scouting that you know you could look
for diseases you could look for insects
you could also do some soil measurements
you can maybe keep track of the nitrate
levels you can do tissue testing things
like that that on a regular basis is a
commitment to monitoring your crop and
then finally you may need to do some
reactive management you may need to
apply a pesticide but it's organic or
inorganic you may need to correct some
nutrient problems and so this is sort of
the the immediate response again going
back to the human health that's more
like taking some antibiotics or taking
some cold medicine so that you on the
short-term can reduce the impact so in a
way what we have
is a range of of management approaches
that we have to use to optimize our crop
what we need to keep in mind is that we
have tended to focus more on the
reactive management but we need to make
sure that we plan ahead of time starting
with a site identification and site
remediation to also do it a long term
preventative management I just wanted to
show you an example of this and this
actually relates to corn production in
Kenya but i think it's it's a very
interesting results from a study from a
few years ago by marina and barrett and
they are basically a agriculture
economist here at cornell and what they
did is they looked at nitrogen response
on lands that had a range of organic
matter content or carbon content and
this is in western kenya where some
soils have been in production for maybe
a hundred years and they tend to have
lower ganic matter contents and other
soils that have been deforested very
recently say in the last five or ten
years that still have a lot of organic
matter and what they found was that when
they applied fertilizer that the
response to fertilizer was much more
favorable for the soils that had a
higher organic matter content than the
searles that had a very low organic
matter content and the this line here is
actually the the price of the fertilizer
which is 200 kenyan shillings in this
case per kilogram and so the soils that
were very degraded and very low in
organic matter didn't actually even have
a provide a profit to the nitrogen
application the reason being that these
soils had a lot of other constraints
because they were low in organic matter
so they may have had higher runoff they
maybe have had compaction problems they
may have been moored rowdy and so you
didn't actually get a good return on
your investment while on these better
soils you did get a much higher return
on your investments so we can think
similarly for other crops that if we
have
low quality soil or unhealthy soil that
we're not going to get as much return on
our investments than if we have a high
quality soil because there are so many
other constraints to deal with when we
have low quality soil so here are a few
other examples of ecological management
your many composts but not all they
suppress root diseases when used in a
potting mix but they also help fight
fight off lease leaf diseases so compost
for example can be actually quite
suppressive of all kinds of disease
problems because with the compost
there's a lot of beneficial organisms
that that help suppress the pathogenic
organisms another example lower
early-season nitrate levels decreased
viability and competitiveness of wheats
with small seeds because these run out
of nutrients more quickly so systems
that are very high in nitrate levels
actually may enhance competition of
undesirable species in this case seeds
another example flea beetle pressure and
damage to cabbage is more severe on
compacted soil this is some work from
Dave wolf here at Cornell that found
that when we have a role in poor health
that the insect pressure tends to be
much higher because the the the plant
isn't it can't resist these kind of
pressures as well another example root
rot severity of vegetable crops is
decreased by growing cover crops in
allowing sufficient time for them to
decompose sometimes we refer to the term
by a fumigation this is work by Georgia
Bobby in the plant pathology department
at Geneva and many cover crop suppress
plant parasitic nematodes also work from
Georgia Bobby's lab so there's a lot of
ecological principles and mutualism that
we can take advantage of when we use
these more agro-ecological approaches
and that reduces the need for these more
reactive approaches which typically
means expensive inputs like pesticides
and fertilizers
so this brings us back to the soil
health test that the optional BEC
discussed in the past few months because
the soil health test is really about
this more proactive long-term management
approach it's not about a quick test
that allows you to respond immediately
as you may remember we have physical
biological and chemical indicators that
we use in a test we measure their values
and we interpret those values into a
rating so we have a way of saying well
if the aggregate stability is twenty-six
percent is that good or is that bad and
we use the rating scale on a scale from
0 to 100 so the end of the main idea
here is then to be able to identify the
constraints which are indicated in red
here and to be able to address these
constraints especially through more
long-term sustainable management
practices so the soil health test
basically is a guide to longer-term
sorel health management when we think
about Barry production we have 2s with
any other crop we have to think about
how do we actually interpret those
values so the aggregate stability is
twenty-six percent is that higher or is
that low and that also depends on what
kind of a crop that we're growing
similarly surface hardness or active
carbon so how do we actually interpret
these numbers and how do we do that for
very production in particular so we
develop these scoring curves that that
Bob discussed and we have basically
three categories one is where more is
better for example generally with
organic matter or active carbon or
aggregate stability the more the higher
the number the better it is in terms of
soil health in other cases we have less
it's better that an example of that
would for example be penetra meter
reading where a high number is actually
less favorable and then
have an optimum for example pH might be
an example of that I think what a key
point that we need to keep in mind is
that we've developed the sural health
test primarily for disturbed systems for
vegetables for field crops and that
these interpretations the scoring curves
would actually vary depending on what
kind of a system we have when we're
dealing with very systems they tend to
be less disturbed and we might have
different expectations another example
is that that some some berry crops
actually do better under a lower pH and
others under a higher pH and certainly
that might be different than something
for a typical vegetable or field crop so
one of the things we need to think about
is how can we how can we enhance and and
and adapt these scoring functions and
these interpretations to an a very
production system so that we can give
better management recommendations so the
way we had approached that with our
initial soil health test development was
to either use a frequency distribution
from our database what we did is we
analyze a lot of samples from basically
very low quality soil and very high
quality soil and everything in between
and then basically look at the
distribution and then develop a scoring
function from that we also use expert
opinion literature values for example
you know we do know what an optimum pH
is for many very crops or ver many
vegetables so we can apply that directly
to our interpretation system so again we
developed the soil health test primarily
for disturbed systems vegetables and
field crops and they would need to be
adapted to perennial systems we may need
to tweak those interpretation curves we
don't need to necessarily change the
measurement methodology we need to
change how we interpret the numbers so
this is just illustrates how we did that
this approach of looking at the
distribution function so if you measure
a lot of these a lot of soils from
variable conditions and you have some
information on how the crops perform on
the soils then you can develop this
distribution function and you can
interpret how you know what's basically
high and what's low and so this for
example is for active carbon so if
you're less than 400 you're basically
pretty low and if you're greater than
800 you're pretty high so that's how you
might want to interpret those numbers
and what we did is we done basically
develop these scoring curves by taking
the normal distribution function and
turning that into a cumulative
distribution function which is just a
simple mathematical trick that you can
do in Excel and then you develop a
scoring function that helps you
interpret your measured value here on
the x-axis and putting that into a score
and with the low scores being in the red
zone and the high scores being in the
Green Zone and the intermediate ones
being in the yellow zone so what would
need to need to happen if we want to
apply this framework to bury crops is we
need to tweak some of the scoring curves
to make them more applicable to vary
crops in general and perhaps to specific
crops like for example ph adjustments
that may be needed depending on what
particular berry crops we're talking
about so here's some
final thoughts then and this is my last
slide so proactive management helps
build resiliency into the cropping
system so this relates to some of the
very early webinars we did where we
talked about site selection site
remediation investing in in compaction
remediation adding organic matter doing
pH correction and all those kind of
things then secondly we may need to do
some reactive management to optimize the
performance so this may involve you know
fertilizer application or sometimes pest
control might be needed so both
proactive and reactive management are
are critical my main point is that we've
tended to not put as much emphasis on
the proactive management and more on the
reactive management soil testing is an
important component and interpretations
need to be refined for very production
and I would say it's Earl testing both
the more conventional Cyril testing
which is really nutrient testing as well
as the more comprehensive testing as we
do in the Cornell's or a health test and
of course organic matter is a key
component this is the life in the soil
and it supports a lot of the organisms
in the soil and that's what allows for
this more agro ecological approach but
we should keep in mind that organic
matter is not not everything we can't
solve all the problems with organic
matter and that was my last slide so at
this point in time I will turn it back
to our moderator Laura thank you very
much I'm wondering if people have
questions right now if there's anything
on your mind I actually do have a
question maybe they start us off with
those scoring functions what volume of
testing what volume of tests do you need
to be able to kind of have some level of
confidence and be able to
make those those scoring functions work
for a perennial crop like berries are we
close to that do we need just a bigger
volume to analyze or how do you get
there from maybe where we are which is
that we need more interpretations or
more information yeah that's said that
that's a good question Laura we you know
we don't have to reinvent a wheel for
this what is important is that we have a
better understanding of you know what
are more or less appropriate or let's
say good levels for some indicators and
and not-so-good levels we did some work
in the past years with the with the
grape group here at Cornell Tim
Mortensen and wailing Chang and Alan
laakso to to apply this or a health test
222 viticulture and of course the the
needs are slightly different in fact
when in viticulture it's a little bit
more complex because often you want the
crop to be somewhat stressed now for
most other Barry crops I don't think
that's that's the case so I I think that
the first step is to basically to to
look at the current scoring functions
and to see what might be appropriate for
example a very obvious change would be
you know what's an optimum pH level for
for a particular very crop and that of
course would vary depending on whether
it's blueberries or raspberries or and
I'm I admit to not being an expert in
this area but I know that that much the
other thing is that you know because
these are more perennial systems that we
may be looking for different values of
say active carbon or organic matter and
so the the best approach I think and you
know in fact that's what what we're
planning to do as part of this grant is
to start collecting some samples from
from berry fields that you know that
hopefully represent a range of
conditions so we need to make sure that
we get samples from some source that we
really know are not performing very well
and we need to have some samples from
soils that we know do perform very well
and so then at least we can start
refining the range and and the boundary
conditions for good versus bad soil and
then it's it's a matter of sitting down
with some experts and then you know
coming up with with good numbers you
need to keep in mind that that that the
numbers that you get out of a soil
health tests are a management guide it
provides you insights like your blood
pressure or your cholesterol level for
for your human health but you know the
the egg that you can't do an exact
interpretation but you can learn a lot
from looking at these sort of Health
reports that allows you to better manage
your soil in your crops okay thank you
um Glenn Taylor from Maine asks is a
soil health test our soil health tests
ready for use in 2012 or still in
development they they are ready in fact
you could submit a sample tomorrow if
you wanted to they are now we we don't
have particular interpretations for
Barry crops but we are receiving samples
and we are providing results that that's
that a professional could certainly
interpret you know part of what we're
trying to do as part you know with this
grant is to is to help develop better
interpretations for Barry crops
specifically and then Oneida County is
wondering what we know about water
management and its effect on very
production if but I'm not sure whether I
quite understand the question but I mean
what we do know is that you know that
both extremes are our problems so we can
have too much water and
then we need to consider drainage
because you know excess water creates a
lot of problems denitrification more you
know pathogenic problems root rot etc
and we can also be on the other end
where we where there may be drought
stress now irrigation is certainly a
more or more reactive approach but we
can build a lot of internal strength in
the system by you know creating a soil
environment that is higher in organic
matter content because organic matter
holds a lot of moisture that allows for
deep rooting so no compacted zones that
that has a correct pH throughout the
profile because roots don't do well in
in acid subsoils so so we can build a
lot of strength in the system by
basically creating a very strong and
extensive routing system yes and I just
want to add to oneida county last week's
of dr. Polanski Santos did talk a little
bit about fertility management and water
management in terms of for more soilless
very production so maybe that would be
of interest to you and Kathy mentioned
in the chat that that webinar plus some
material associated with it she is going
to be posting on the website and sending
a link to those of you who are on our
email list which i think is everybody
there Kathy also sent out an email to
folks wondering if they had any kind of
unresolved questions from the very
series and now might be a time if
anybody does have those or Kathy i don't
know if anybody emailed you back with
anything about that Laura I didn't I
didn't get anybody with any burning
unresolved questions but if anyone he
has any it would be great to bring those
out now
okay Wow oh maybe Lee has something
there's no pressure Lee we're just all
watching to see how quickly you tight
neck is supposed to allow us to have to
be able to turn on each of your if you
had a headset we could independently
allow you an opportunity to speak we
have not tried that yet but maybe in
some other setting you will try that
because this is the problem this is the
challenge is the typing part but thanks
for your patience everybody
the least comment is about submitting
multiple samples two from each of two
growers the results very interesting and
yeah i agree Lee I think this is
fascinating stuff we've just begun
working on it with vegetable growers and
I did do a couple with some very growers
in a reduced till study and and it is
not you know we think we know what's
going on in the soil but it is really
surprising when soil health tests come
back and proves that we don't know
everything about it just from you know
what we expect but yeah that's great and
Oneida County mentions the handouts and
website information will be helpful and
that is true and I'm going to take it
that people are done with questions so
why don't we move into the very last
portion portion thank you very much dr.
Van Ness Kathy heidenreich is now going
to give us a little summary and lay out
the next phase of the project so thanks
a lot Kathy thanks Laura and I'll ask
everyone to excuse me I'm just
recovering from a cold so I sound a
little bit like Dom duck today so what I
want to do just briefly is to review the
purpose of the project with you and give
you an idea where we are in the timeline
and where we'd like to go from here and
how you might play a role in that so the
issue that has been that commercial
berry growers in the Northeast
traditionally make standard fertilizer
applications based on crop age and as
dr. Vanessa pointed out so aptly today
it's it's a reactive sort of management
versus proactive and this is in spite of
the fact that for ten years or more we
have some very good research that
indicates that analysis based
fertilization programs really are more
beneficial most in terms of dollars and
cents and in terms of yield and plant
health and that soil health can also
have an impact and soil health
improvement techniques have also not
been adapted
vary widely among berry growers and so
we have a concern about that so when we
started looking into why this might be
so we discovered that educators the
folks who have been participating in
particular are often called on to cover
multiple commodities and sometimes
they're actually operating outside their
field of expertise and so it's a
struggle to help Barry growers with soil
and nutrient management problems and
then also with interpretation of things
like there's the Cornell soil health
test results or the foliar analysis
results and that we didn't have any
comprehensive resources on this to help
people do that so dr. Marvin pritts and
the the team have put together a
two-year project to help provide some
training both for educators and for the
berry growers and so this webinar series
has actually been here one of the plan
we can check that off now we've worked
through the 12 webinars together and
while you've been working through the
webinars we've been working on resources
that you will be able to use in grower
training and so the next phase is where
we're hoping that it's your turn and
that you'll assist us by providing some
training to growers and so we're going
to look at that in a little more detail
so how we're going to measure the
success we're going to look at knowledge
before and after participating in the
project to see what sort of changes may
have occurred and then we're also going
to look at adoption and success of
analysis based nutrient and soil
management in years to follow after the
project so we had 72 educators when we
started we've had various numbers of
educators throughout and so we've
accomplished the first goal and the
second goal we'd like to have 15 of you
who've been willing to train to actually
develop and delivers an outreach program
and we're hoping that we'll get at least
10 growers at each or more
at each training and then that 50 of
them will participate in a soil and
nutrient management health testing and
so we have complementary Cornell soil
health tests for 50 growers we also have
complementary foliar analysis test for
the same 50 and then we're hoping that
educators who sponsor training will work
one on one with the growers to interpret
the results and to come up with some
sort of a plan to implement on farm and
then that the same educators will
collect feedback from the growers on how
well they think it worked so let's talk
about where we're going from here so in
terms of the webinar I do have a list of
people we were missing demographics
questionnaires from and I'll be mailing
emailing them and letting them know and
there's a post-test remember in the on
the first webinar we went through 20
questions to test your knowledge to see
where you were starting from there is a
survey monkey survey and if you look in
the bottom left-hand box the web's links
box you'll see the post-test there and
you're able to take that that will be
open for a month in case you haven't had
a chance to finish all the webinars or
you need to go back and listen to the
recording of that one you missed and
then there's also an evaluation so we're
asking that each person who participated
whether you only saw one webinar whether
you went through all 12 would do both
the post-test and the evaluation and
I'll be sending out an email reminder on
that as well so now it's your turn so
what we're hoping to have well we will
have is materials available for you to
assit to assist you with grower training
we have some web pages that are under
development that are nearing completion
you'll be able to have those available
as well and to provide input as to their
utility and how what may be missing or
what would be useful that may not be
offered their the members of the team
will be available to assist on request
and i'm going to be posting training
dates on the ark webinar archive
page so that we can try to avoid
overlaps and training because I'm
convinced of course that everyone want
to go out and do this so what we'll have
in terms of grower training materials is
a one-hour PowerPoint presentation
that's going to discuss Cornell soil
health test and the assessment and then
foliar analysis and it can be used in a
classroom or field setting will have a
set of grower pre and post test
questions to go with that maybe a short
set five or ten questions so that we can
measure knowledge before and knowledge
knowledge after will have some sample
test results for group exercises
remember when Marvin and Eric talked
about the test results and what sort of
mediation would be needed and also
Robert with a soil health test and then
apart from that in terms of your grower
training you're able to add whatever
bits and pieces you might like from you
know playing the recorded webinars
having guest speakers covering other
topics really you can cater it to the
needs of your growers so once your
training is complete we're going to ask
you to select some participating growers
to participate in the soil health test
and the foliar analysis and then at
we're going to have a standard operating
procedure that will make available to
you and them which will discuss how they
might implement at least one or two of
the practices on their farm on a portion
of their crop and then we would also ask
them to participate in an exit interview
to share their insights on the crop
health and performance of the new
practices that they've implemented
versus their standard practice and so
you'll be hearing for me in the next
couple of weeks we hope many of you will
be interested in participating and we
want to thank you very much for being a
part of the webinar series all right
Thank You Kathy there is a couple of
questions or at least Lee has a question
about funding to support the outreach
program i'm lee we didn't we didn't have
that in the budget for the project we
specifically were interested in building
the numbers of soil health tests we had
to go into the database so that we could
start working on those recommendations
so we we focused the the funds in that
in that area
okay and we can put your email we can
put the email right here in the chat box
if you'd like mark and so so the links
are there for the educator post-test if
you're ready to take that now certainly
you could do the webinar series
evaluation probably because you don't
need to listen to all of them in order
to complete that but we do hope to hear
from all of you I think this is a rather
exciting way to get training out to a
large amount of people so I hope
everyone is able to take advantage of it
and if you have any other questions
please okay so there are a couple more
questions the outreach program targeted
only to Northeast states Bob wonders I'm
Bob that's a good question and it's not
necessarily only Northeast states that's
the primary focus of Northeast air but
we really are interested in getting 50
growers lined up and so once I have an
idea of once people have let me know
who's interested in having a training
i'll have a better handle on that and
i'll be able to talk to you about that
specifically and initially what we
decided to do would be we have 50
complimentary sets of tests depending on
how many grower trainings that we have
we're thinking about dividing them
amongst the number of trainings and so
Sharon in terms of first come first
serve basis no not necessarily educators
who are hosting training say we have 10
educators who host training we have 50
tests then we would have five tests
available for each training if we have
four people you know we could have 12
and a half for each training so you kind
of get the idea so so far we have four
scheduled and they're listed in the box
on the right and we're hoping to in the
next couple of weeks to get the other
scheduled and then we'll know how many
tests we have available and that's if
you scroll down in the notes box there
are some grower training dates and South
Cairo I'm
arch 28 Greenwich New York on March 29
may 9th in water port New York and made
tenth and Williamson New York so there
are some opportunities and we will have
more information about them you know
exact contact information and stuff in
case someone would like to go and watch
how it's done or just want to advertise
it to your growers but we do hope that
you will go ahead and most of your very
experienced growers or educator so this
should not be a problem especially when
you have all of the equipment to do the
training with do we have any other
questions either about content for about
the administrative kind of approach of
the grant so if not I'm going to leave
this webinar classroom open for about 15
extra minutes let people go to the
webinar series evaluation and complete
that survey monkey we really appreciate
all of your time at the speakers time
and Cathy especially Hugh is now busy
trying to get the website and all the
materials up together thank you very
much and good luck with your training
everybody
you